a Follies one actor gives new meaning to
the phrase look ma no hands and what do
your sleeping habits say about you
joining us with all the very important
details Raymond Arroyo Fox News
contributor all right Raymond counter
reads is getting a lot of praise for an
odd Ruiz he is they're calling him a
respectful King online right now this
comes from a series of photographs that
surfaced online showing Keanu in
photographs with women and in each shot
if you look closely the 54 year old
actor the John wick actor has his hands
open he's not hugging or making contact
with the back of these ladies now he's
being lauded for his respect for
personal space and bodily autonomy now
this is all nice but this makes me think
kiha who looks more like John shtick at
this point Laura this is not their Miss
reading this they're saying oh he's so
respectful this is called
self-preservation
exactly in the me2 movement moment he
doesn't want these people coming back at
him I have a friend who's a huge star
every picture he takes us like this he
smiles and crosses his arms he does that
so they can't come back later and say
you grabbed me but it is odd do you know
Keanu with the open hands Keanu Andrea
and Keanu Reeves and Joe Biden should
talk he could be a consultant but
oftentimes isn't touching when he's
smelling the hair right so that's just
smelling is that part of your personal
space your odor I don't know we'll have
to check with John wick now there's a
new study that I have to tell you about
that we can all learn a great deal from
people are very territorial about the
side of the bed they sleep on why'd you
switch science be grateful I'm still in
the room
now in a study conducted by a group
called one poll they found that if you
sleep on the left side of the bed you
are not more imaginative and creative
and if you sleep on the right
you're more analytical and logical where
do you sleep
I'm on the right how do you know
see I'm is this pillow right or foot of
the bed right I can't feel oh right you
mean it's you're in the bed as you're in
the bed well then you sleep well I sleep
on the left then but does that mean I'm
more creative and a little I've grave
doubt so I read somewhere that it also
means your politics that means you're a
quiet liberal well you see I'm the
moderation forty percent of people or
say they select the site of the bid
easiest for them to get in and out of
now I think I choose mine because of
hotels I'll sleep on the other side I
think I choose it because of bathroom
proximity no what does that say don't
drop me that's what I instinctively I
think I think we have those advertisers
covered okay so we've got your help for
you all right do you sleep with your TV
on that's my question Lord to the watts
according to the medical journal JAMA
sleeping with the TV or a light on is
associated with weight gain and women up
to 11 pounds can be added over five
years so don't turn that Netflix weight
everywhere even when you don't have a TV
I'm gonna get I have a TV I never turn
Rebecca and I go around the room with
you know cuz you have the light on your
cable wake up we have little coverings
we put over them it's a little ritual
okay this is Raymond at Normandy because
Raymond had to sleep in the car so we
slept in the car which of course we had
to tell the president we slept in yes
he looked just like you're weird and so
I look over and we look through the
glass and Raymond has one of those
airplane masks on as the porta potti
doors are slamming back and forth I'm
walking around yes you can sleep gotta
sleep finally the 60-year old material
girl she's reinventing herself
Donna as part of the release of her new
album Madame X she's wearing an eyepatch
and has assumed a new identity which she
shared with Harry Smith do you have a
patch on your eyes okay yes I do miss an
x on it yes Madame axe that's correct
she's a spy she's a secret agent she
travels the world she changes her
identity she is out of her mind this is
Madame Rex but she has inspired me Laura
I am this weekend going to be mr. thin
I'm blocking out all the fattening light
rays I'm going to simply sleep like this
all Father's Day and I'm keeping my
hands open wide whenever ladies are near
well great weekend wonderful fall like a
prayer we want that borderline of crazy
expected all this let's do the Pall Mall
commercials a tour it's not selling
madam X X is what's going to be at the
bottom of that balance sheet